[موسيقى]
القائد الحكيم هو الذي يعرف كيف يتجنب
الحرب
لكنه اذا اضطر لها يعرف كيف يقهر خصمه ولا
يبقى مجرد رده فعل لتحركات اعدائه اهلا
بكم في عسكرتا
[موسيقى]
كندا تنه جدلا استغرق عقدا من الزمن
وتتعاقد رسميا على شراء 88 طائره مقاتله
من طراز اف 35 ايه الامريكيه بقيمه تصل
الى نحو 14 مليارا ومائتين مليون دولار
امريكي في صفقه تعد اضخم في تاريخ القوات
الجويه الكنديه منذ ثلاثه عقود مقاتله
الجيل الخامس الشبحيه ستحل محل الاسطول
الكندي من قاتلات سي اف 18 ومن المتوقع ان
يبدا تسليم الطائرات بحلول عام 2026
وينتهي بحلول عام 2034
انعكاسا لتهديدات الدوليه الحاليه التي
تلعب فيها الصواريخ دورا ريسيا شركه
رافايل الاسرائيليه اعلنت تطوير منظومه
للدفاع الجوي تسمى سبايدر لتشمل الحمايه
من الصواريخ البالسيه التكتيكيه تطوير
المنظومه يشمل تحديث الاجهزه والبرامج
وصاروخ ديربي ال ار الاعتراضي كما ان
ترقيات الاخيره التي نفذتها الشركه جاءت
بسبب متطلبات العملاء الذين يتعاملون معها
نجحت طائره بوينغ من طراز اف 15 اي اكس اي
جيل تو في احدث اختباراتها في اطلاقه
صاروخين جووا لاستهدافي احدى المسيارات من
محطات اطلاق جديده هذه المحطات تم اضافتها
لطائره بهذه التحديثات تقترب الطائره من
كونها الاكثر قدره على حمل الصواريخ داخل
الاسطول الجوي الامريكي
اكثر حموله للمقاتلات الامريكيه الخليه لا
تتجاوز ثمانيه صواريخ